i feel like i'm a softie you are a
softie but you go and decay rage and
then
i do get very i mean i have [ __ ]
range that says k rage
there's a t-shirt yeah yeah yeah someone
made a t-shirt that says k-ray
i have so much rape me too ah that's
great i do have
that yeah the rage and mean recognizes
the rage in you
you have carriage too oh yeah immense
yeah
yeah i tried to like keep it down with
weed but like it flares up
yeah it's like eczema it's like once a
month it really gets bad
i thought it was a hereditary thing like
just for my i got it from my dad
same the rage but i think now
in retrospect if i look at all the
koreans that i know
there is a level of anger there
that where does that stem from i think
it's just
oppression yeah oppression you so you
think that that
rage derived from when the japanese
occupied korea for 50 years i think even
before with like mongolia and [ __ ] like
wow so you think it's ingrained inside
us to have
trauma is if trauma is hereditary it
stays in your genes so i really think
that
why are filipinos so [ __ ] nice then i
think it's because it's recent
maybe i don't know the oppressor 300
years
and then the japanese did to us what
they did to you oh my god and then we
had the americans
who gave us fake freedom just to put
like bases in the country
and we're still a third world country
yeah why you guys are all happy
oh my god you go back home i'm telling
you like everyone is
doesn't have a lot but is exponentially
happier than americans
yeah okay and there's no such thing
i think it has to do with atmosphere of
their where they grew up
i mean you're in paradise so like how
angry can you be yeah yeah
you know like we got everything we have
a lot of snow it gets really even
during the summers gets really rainy
kind of hot and hot muggy
and the winters are super cold i think
that um
i don't know man it's it's just
something that um
you guys didn't face your demons you
think that's what he knows they talk
about
it yeah there's a lot of suppression
there's yeah that's a lot of suppression
i think that's what it is
yeah but that's why i like bobby because
everyone here is like
let's just talk about everything and
bobby just like flips out and
calls me fat [ __ ] and i'm like yeah give
it to me
yeah it's weird like i'm used to it
yes it's funny that you say that because
it's like when comics
rip on me right yeah yeah and i somehow
just absorb it
i love it i love it i absorb it it
doesn't offend me
you know it's like i don't get
threatened by
anything verbal usually like even as a
kid people go you're a [ __ ]
you go that's right yeah i am or you
know back in the day when you know
people used to call people chicken right
and the men would
get offended yeah not me no call me call
me it's copy chicken
but my point is is that i use humorous
defense magazines but
i do have this like dude you know my bro
i'm not gonna tell you what we thought
about but my brother and i
last week i think was last week it was
yeah last week
it got to the point i was screaming at
my brother so
hard that the phone just shut off jesus
like it was so it like my phone went you
know like siri couldn't handle it and my
girl
my girlfriend and then um steve calls me
back and he's now my
brother my brother's calm and he goes i
don't want to [ __ ] you with you anymore
because you're going to get a stroke
like he knew that i was at a level
of i could have had a stroke oh my god i
was screaming at him
so [ __ ] i would have killed him if he
was right in front of me but he that's
after
he said he would kill you first right
yeah i forgot who threatened who but
you told me that he was like bro i have
knives remember
yeah you did say you brought up the
knives again yeah now
last week he did geez yeah he always
brings up knives which is like that
that's so asian
we don't fight with guns yeah we do
sashimi stuff
bro yeah yeah yeah story oh yeah yeah
knives is also like very personal um oh
when you kill somebody
intimate yeah you lock up look at him
right yeah yeah yeah right and [ __ ]
sore subject for me
oh yeah oh my god you were stabbed yeah
oh my
uncle killed my other uncle in broad
daylight with like a
sword and basically a machete
and we're gonna go see him in a couple
days his name is uncle carlo remember
him he'll come to the airport